l'orge a ouvert le bal des moissonneuses
batteuses mi juin en région centre
première région productrice d'orge
d'hiver on s'attend finalement à de bons
rendements la vague de chaleur est
arrivé à un moment où les épis était
déjà bien avancé autre bonne nouvelle
des cours historiquement haut à cause de
la guerre en ukraine les céréales se
vendent très bien même si les prix
tombent à redescendre on fait le point
du côté de cheminer sur un droit avec
romain delville
ça y est les orges d'hiver sont fauchés
dans le département et donne le départ
des moissons c'était murs depuis une
semaine donc on avait encore mona une
moissonneuse batteuse à plusieurs donc
on avait fait les autres parcelles avant
et on a fini par ici et on a récolté nos
âges divers toute la semaine dernière
pour le président de la chambre
d'agriculture qui cultive une centaine
d'hectares de céréales à chemillé sur un
droit l'année est exceptionnelle à plus
d'un titre les conditions météo avec un
large déficit de pluie durant l'hiver
associé à des températures parfois
caniculaires ce dernier mois ont fait
craindre le pire aux agriculteurs henri
frémont et ses collègues sont
agréablement surpris de la récolte de
l'orge au niveau mondial l'invasion
militaire de la russie en ukraine a
d'abord eu des conséquences sur le prix
des intrants le prix de l'engrais azoté
a multiplié par trois et maintenant ce
sont les cours du prix des céréales qui
s'affolent il était très élevé il ya un
mois ont baissé d'une vingtaine de
pourcents depuis mais reste haut on est
dans un monde de spéculation qui est
quand même extrêmement important et la
personne n'est capable de dire ce qui
peut se passer demain si le prix de
langeais continue de baisser comme
aujourd'hui aussi et rauque monter le
prix des céréales aussi je pense que
c'est principalement la spéculation qui
a fait monter les prix des céréales à
ceux à ce niveau là je pense que tout ça
va se régulariser aussi en temps normal
l'ukraine est une redoutable concurrente
dans le commerce du blé et des céréales
en général cette année la guerre risque
de créer la famine dans certains coins
du monde avec la spéculation les
producteurs céréaliers sont dans le flou
jusqu'à la fin des moissons dans la
deuxième quinzaine de juillet